-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
President Biden on Monday
announced the so-called
billionaire minimum income tax
as part of his 2023 budget --
specifically, the part
they'll have to cut out
before it will pass.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday signed
an anti-lynching bill into law
and not, as I would have hoped,
President Buchanan.
[ Laughter ]
After meeting with
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
yesterday for the second time,
Republican senator Susan Collins
told reporters
she felt Jackson had met
her personal standard
for serving
on the Supreme Court,
which is blowing anything
under a .08 on a breathalyzer.
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that it would not invoke
executive privilege
to shield Jared Kushner
from testifying
before the House committee
investigating
the Capitol attack.
And if indicted,
he could be tried as an adult.
[ Laughter ]
After it was reported
that former President Trump
may have communicated
during the Capitol attack
using so-called burner phones,
Trump released a statement
on Monday that said,
"I have no idea
what a burner phone is.
To the best of my knowledge, I
have never even heard the term."
[ Laughter ]
I love the way he always goes a
little too far with his denials.
It's like if someone said,
"Hey, man, I haven't seen
your wife lately,"
and you said, "I wouldn't even
know how to poison someone."
[ Laughter ]
"And I sure as hell
don't own a shovel."
[ Laughter ]
After facing criticism
for his plan
to clear homeless encampments
from the city,
New York mayor Eric Adams
told reporters yesterday,
"I'm like broccoli.
You're going to hate me now,
but you're gonna love me later."
Well, okay, but just speaking
for myself,
it's been 48 years on broccoli.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
eating just two servings
of avocado a week
can reduce the risk of having
a heart attack by more than 20%.
So, yeah, still no such thing
as affordable healthcare.
[ Laughter ]
Two avocados a week?
Who's making
two-avocados-a-week money?
[ Laughter ]
Walgreens has announced plans
to open robot-powered
fulfillment centers
across the U.S.
to help fill prescriptions,
with each robotic pharmacist
able to complete
300 prescriptions an hour,
which will give you more time
to wait for someone
to come unlock the razors.
[ Laughter ]
[ As robot ]
Robot does not unlock razors.
[ Normal voice ] Come on,
you've got robot hands.
[ As robot ]
No, robot does not.
Only fill prescriptions.
That is Steve's job.
[ Normal voice ]
Where's Steve?
[ As robot ]
Steve is on break.
[ Laughter ]
No, robot --
[ Laughing ]
Steve never tell robot
where he is going.
[ Laughter ]
Make robot sad.
Steve robot best friend.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Normal voice ] According --
According to new reports,
Apple is set to make
10 million fewer AirPods
than anticipated this year
due to rising inflation,
so maybe think twice before
walking over a sewer grate.
"Aww!
Aw, man, my AirPod.
I don't got the money for more.
I already bought
my two avocados."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor of Easter,
Disney World will offer
a so-called Boozy Bunny,
which features
a chocolate rabbit
filled with a bourbon drink.
It's the perfect treat
for people
who shouldn't be
at Disney World.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.